[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
All right, I'm going
to get started.
This is lecture 22 on 14.13 on
happiness and mental health.
OK, so what are we going
to talk about today?
Happiness and
subjective well-being
and a little bit
of mental health.
So we're going to talk about
rationality and revealed
preferences and what can
we learn from choices,
and what does that tell
us about happiness.
We also talked about utility
and how we can measure utility.
In particular, how do
we measure happiness,
and is that a good or bad idea?
And then at the very
end, we'll have,
hopefully, a llama
or a goat visit,
which will at least improve my
happiness, hopefully yours too.
I've had some trouble
communicating by email
with the llama, goat,
and their keepers.
So I'm not exactly
sure when they're
going to show up, so
they're scheduled--
the problem is, so they had only
different certain time slots.
The only time slot that
was available was at 2:30,
so I asked them to show
up earlier, 2:20 or so.
I hope that's actually
going to happen,
but I haven't heard back,
so I'm not exactly sure.
So it might have
to be at like 2:30.
I hope you don't have to run.
There was also some
confusion about which
Zoom room code the
llama should go into,
and hopefully,
they find our room,
even though they
don't have and MIT ID.
So anyway, that's that.
And then on Monday, we're
going to talk about policy
with people agents, which
is very much the idea that,
well, now if people are
potentially making mistakes
or have certain
biases and we might
think that we know
about it, then
perhaps we can do policies
to improve their behaviors.
And in some cases,
that's straightforward.
If you think people have
biased beliefs or just
have wrong information based
on which they make information,
then you might say, well,
it should have just improved
their information, and then
they make better choices.
In other situations,
it's much trickier,
because A, people might have
certain preferences that
are not stable
over time, and then
it's very tricky to figure out
what is the objective function
that we should maximize.
Second, it might be tricky
because who knows what we
know versus what people know?
So who knows that the
government or anybody else
knows actually better what's
good for other people?
So in some sense, if
you want to intervene,
you better be reasonably
confident that what you're
doing is actually
well founded and you
know better what's
good for people
than they know about themselves.
And that gets you in
tricky situations,
because potentially,
if you get it wrong,
or maybe if you
just misunderstand
people's preferences, or
their choices, or behaviors,
then you might
intervene and make
things actually [AUDIO OUT]
because you just misunderstood
[AUDIO OUT].
OK.
So what is rationality
in classical economics?
How do we [AUDIO OUT]?
So broadly, we think that
beliefs, preferences,
and actions are rational if
they are mutually consistent.
What do we mean by that?
Well, we mean by
that that if we see
certain behavior
or certain actions,
we can measure people's
beliefs in certain ways.
And then we essentially
can find preferences
that could rationalize
these actions.
And so that's a
very odd definition,
and without that definition,
we can essentially
say it's possible to be a
rational cocaine addict.
It's possible to
rationally commit suicide.
rationally marry somebody
who you met six hours ago.
And it's also possible to be
rational violent offender.
If there's preferences
that people have,
you could write down some
preferences that rationalize
all of those things.
And so [AUDIO OUT] in
mainstream economics very much
a main assumption.
So the researchers'
jobs is to identify
preferences that are consistent
with observed human behavior.
So when you see people
[AUDIO OUT] way,
so then the question
is like, what
are preferences that
rationalize that behavior?
Now what's the idea?
We talked about
this already before.
So actors make
choices, economists
observe their choices,
and then [AUDIO OUT]
generate these choices if an
actor were perfectly rational.
[AUDIO OUT] tend to give
these imputed preferences
normative meaning.
That's essentially, if I
know your preferences, that
[AUDIO OUT].
And that's what you should be
doing, as in, if you prefer B,
I should be helping
you to do that.
That would be a
good thing for you.
Now just to give you
an example of where
this could lead you
potentially astray,
or where you might argue,
is that really rational
versus not, for example,
take Jack, who prefers
taking cocaine over quitting.
Jack has lots of speeches about
wanting to quit, but in a way,
he doesn't actually act on.
That's just cheap talk.
Jack might, in fact, be
[AUDIO OUT] if he were clean.
But getting clean is too
costly, because there
are withdrawal costs.
Jack probably didn't [INAUDIBLE]
[AUDIO OUT] tried cocaine,
but this bad outcome was
sufficiently unlikely that his
early experiments
with it made sense.
So finally, cocaine should
be legalized unless it
generates externalities.
That's essentially,
people make choices.
They make-- if Jack
started taking it,
it must have been that
he preferred cocaine
over not taking cocaine,
even though there's
a chance that [AUDIO OUT]
get really addicted
and really be miserable now.
And probably even if he keeps
taking cocaine and [AUDIO OUT]
to quit-- well, if
he doesn't do it,
well, then it must be a
rational choice for him
to, not because it must
be that the withdrawal
costs are really high.
Now we talked a little
bit about this theory
of rational addiction, much
about Becker and Murphy.
We talked about
already that there's
present bias or other
factors involved,
including biased beliefs.
That might not be the case.
[INAUDIBLE] understand
that traditional economics,
until very recently, would say
that the rational thing to do
with Jack here--
in fact, no good reason to make
certain or any drugs illegal on
externalities.
So externalities would
be like if Jack causes
behavior that's bad for others.
Then well, we
shouldn't let him do
that, because other
people are harmed
and you might not
internalize [INAUDIBLE]..
But unless that's the case, we
shouldn't intervene in any way.
OK, but so now, you might say,
but what did we talk about
in all [INAUDIBLE]?
How is that consistent with
what we talked about before?
And the key of that
question is the question of,
do people act in
their best interest?
And so what we
essentially assume often
is that there is a rational
relationship between people's
choices, what they actually do,
and the hedonic consequences
of those choices, which
are true well-being.
And so what we
assume is essentially
that you make certain choices
that maximize your well-being.
Essentially what you
learned in 14.01 or 14.03
is essentially
utility maximization,
and that's at the heart of
the rationality assumptions.
So economists then
tend to believe
that most of the time, people
act, at least approximately,
in their best interest.
Now as we talked about
already, and this
is our previous lecture
about Nisbett and Wilson
telling more than we can know,
we should be actually quite
skeptical about the fact
that people actually
know what they're doing
and why they're doing it,
because [INAUDIBLE],, as I showed
you last time, in some sense,
people often seem to
have essentially no clue
of why they do what they do.
So it seems like a bit
of an odd assumption
to say, well, people
are maximizing
what's best for them.
So now how can we check whether
this assumption is appropriate?
What would you do?
So I'm telling you
here some behaviors.
How can you actually check
whether this assumption
is an appropriate one?
Lauren.
AUDIENCE: We could
check their well-being
after they make these
decisions and if they're
better or worse off.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, and
we have to somehow figure out
some situations where we can
track people's well-being.
Ideally, we would have
some sort of experiment.
There's group A and B, and
in group A [INAUDIBLE],,
you let them choose, and
in the other groups--
[INAUDIBLE] group
C-- in some group,
we essentially tell people,
you should be doing A,
doing one thing, and
another group, we say,
you should be doing
another thing.
And then there's
another group where we
have people essentially choose.
And then you can look at--
track people's well-being.
And then we could
figure out, is the group
that gets to choose
actually doing better
than maybe some groups where
we actually just tell them
what to do?
And in some ways, or the work
by Dan Ariely and others,
if I can essentially
manipulate you
into making very drastically
different choices by changing
small things that
really, arguably,
should be irrelevant
for your choice,
like for example, the
Social Security number--
for example, if I
could manipulate
you with anchoring you with
your social security number
and then say, would you like
to purchase this item for $10,
yes or no, and that
affects your choice,
well, then presumably,
that's a clue in some ways
that something is
not going right.
And so you are not
necessarily optimizing,
precisely because the Social
Security number really
should be entirely
irrelevant, arguably.
Some forms of what
we talked about,
like preference reversal,
or some form of demand
from commitment or the like.
If that's the case, it seems
to be that then there's
self control problems
involved or biased beliefs
in various ways that
we all talked about,
which seems then sent
to say, well, you
keep saying you want one thing.
You keep spending money on, say,
healthy eating, but then you
never--
the food all goes
bad in your fridge,
and you keep eating donuts.
That seems to be
something that's
not quite-- don't seem to
be maximizing your utility.
But in general,
it would be great
if you could measure
behavior and then
the hedonic consequences of
those behaviors, people's
well-being, and if
you then could say,
well, option A or option B is
better for people in general,
or specifically when
you ask them to choose,
they can figure out
what's best for them.
Notice that you need to know
the counterfactual here.
You can't-- if I see you
doing one thing and then track
your well-being,
it's not enough,
because I don't know
the counterfactual,
whether you would be happy
otherwise if you were not
to choose that, OK.
So great idea.
So now, how do we
actually do that?
So it's useful to have
some terminology here
that, in particular, that
Kahneman and others have
introduced.
And Kahneman, remember, this
is from Tversky and Kahneman,
the Nobel Prize
winner, who worked
a lot on loss aversion
and prospect theory
that we talked about.
Then Kahneman also has quite
a bit of work on well-being
and happiness and so on.
So and he introduces
very useful terminology,
which is-- they call decision
utility and experience utility.
So now what's decision utility?
So economists tend to use
the word utility or utility
function to describe the
preferences that rationalize
observed choices.
Essentially, if you took
14.01, 14.03, et cetera,
people talk about
the utility function.
Essentially, it's the function
that you write down that maps
your choices into well-being.
And the function
that you maximize,
or by maximizing it, essentially
say, well, given this utility
function, given
your behavior, it
must be this utility function
or that utility function
allows me to rationalize
what you're doing.
That actually allows
me then to explain why
you choose apples over bananas.
And so Kahneman calls
these revealed preferences
the decision utility.
That's essentially
the preferences
that rationalize decisions.
When people make choices, that's
the utility that they perceive
or that they think they
will perceive or receive
as a consequence
of their choices.
That's essentially-- you might
call that wanting or choosing.
So quickly, for an addict,
the decision utility
of drug consumption exceeds the
decision utility of quitting.
So if that person makes the
decision of taking drugs,
it must be that their
decision utility is higher.
When making those choices,
they prefer one option
over the other, which,
again, doesn't necessarily
then mean that afterwards, the
experience is actually better.
But when making the
choice of taking the drug,
they think that's a
better option for them.
Now in contrast,
Kahneman also talks
about experience neutrality,
which implies or talks
about the hedonic
consequences of choices.
He calls these hedonic
experiences experience utility.
That's essentially
the preferences
that coincide with doing.
So while you actually experience
the whole consequences
of your choice, what
experience do you
have, and what utility,
or what's your well-being
during that?
That's actually going
back a long time ago.
If you look at some of the
wards in economics, Bentham
and others, they talk a lot
about pleasure and pain, which
is very much about
the experience
people have in their life,
as opposed to utility,
which is, again, the construct
that you have at the time
of [INAUDIBLE].
Now how do we measure
these hedonic experiences
of well-being?
So there's two
questions, I guess.
One is, how can we measure this?
If I wanted to know, what
is your hedonic experience
of this lecture right
now, how would I do this?
How do you enjoy, how
much do you enjoy things?
And then second, well, I
can measure your experience
right now, maybe this
moment, maybe this hour,
but somehow I need to
aggregate those over time.
I need to know, you took
class A versus class B.
Now I can measure you at
different points of time,
but somehow, then
I need to aggregate
this overall experience.
And how people are doing that
is [INAUDIBLE] some questions.
Let's start with
the first question,
how do you measure
people's well-being?
If you wanted to learn
about your classmates'
experience in any type of
situations, what would you do?
What would you measure?
One is you can ask
them verbally, like,
how did you like activity
A, how do you like B,
or feel [AUDIO OUT] now?
So this is asking
what people want.
But also just look at their
facial features or the like
and try to see how much
they're smiling or the like.
Notice that that, you need
to map into some happiness
as well.
In some sense, I could be
smiling but be deeply unhappy,
and then you would
misinterpret that.
So you'd have to have some
function from facial feature
to some underlying
well-being that's somewhat
grounded in some assumptions.
It seems reasonable to think
that when people are smiling,
they're happy, and when they're
crying, they're unhappy,
but I'm just pointing out that
that requires some underlying
data to be able to
map those things.
One is the physiological
measures such as heart rates,
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
And so there, again, I
think commonsensical stuff,
like if you're really afraid and
your heart goes up, presumably
that's not a good thing.
But if you're really excited
and your heart rate goes up,
presumably that's a good thing.
So one has to add some
assumptions or some structure
on these measures.
In some sense, you're just
measuring them by themselves.
In general, it
might be misleading,
but with some structure,
[INAUDIBLE] use that well.
The other part is measuring--
there's lots of neuroscience
and other work on this.
Measuring people's brain
and parts of the brain,
and seeing which parts
light up at which times
could be another option.
Of course, again there,
you need to map that
into something else.
So you need to then
be able to say,
suppose I do something nice
for you or [INAUDIBLE],,
and I can then figure out
which parts of the brain
are affected.
And then I can use
that then to later,
now if I wanted to figure
out, suppose I could measure
your brains during lecture.
If I had figured out earlier
which parts of the brain
are associated with happy
versus unhappy things,
and now I could see what
your brains are doing
during lecture, I
could then figure out
whether you are
happy or unhappy.
But notice you need to have
some mapping, because otherwise,
it's hard to interpret
what's going on.
But of course, people
have already worked a lot
on that, that kind of mapping.
And just to be clear,
so the revealed
preference measures are--
hold on, let me just
share what I have here.
But the revealed
preference measures
are useful for some
things, but in a way,
if you wanted to measure whether
revealed preferences give you
a good answer, then of course,
the real preference measure
is not helpful.
Or put differently, you
want to check precisely.
Suppose if I ask you, do you
want lecture A or lecture B,
and then everybody says they
want lecture A-- or whatever,
good A or good B, and everybody
says they want good A--
the econ assumption is,
by revealed preference,
it must be that A makes
you happier than B.
But if I wanted to the test,
is that actually true, then I
need to have your
revealed preference,
but then I also need to
know your counterfactual
in some sense.
So I'd say give you good
A, and I'd give you good B.
How would that make you?
So I need the
measures that we have
here in the slides,
a version of that,
to say, OK, I'm going to look
at your facial expression
and see how happy you
look when I give you
good A versus good B.
Or I look at your brain
and see which parts of
it-- do the pleasure
parts of your brain light up?
And if that's the
case, I'm going
to conclude that you're happier
with good A versus good B,
or if that's more so
the case for good A.
And then I can look at
your revealed preference.
Is it really the case
that you choose A over B,
if the experienced utility says
A makes you happier than B?
Does that make sense?
OK.
So what are these techniques?
[AUDIO OUT] I think we
covered most of [AUDIO OUT]..
There's the observer
ratings, facial [AUDIO OUT],,
reports of mood, pain,
pleasure, happiness, and so on.
This is what [AUDIO OUT].
There's autonomic
measures, which
is the respiratory,
cardiovascular, your blood
pressure, or your pulse, and
so on, and so forth-- sweat.
There's vocal measures as well,
which is pitch, loudness, tone.
And you can probably
detect whether somebody
is angry or excited and so on.
And again, you can
apply some mapping here.
You can look at people's brains.
There's also some responses
to emotion sensitive tasks.
So if I ask you, do you
want to talk to a friend
or do you want us to
do something nice,
and if the answer is,
no, absolutely not,
it could obviously
be you're busy.
But when people
are in a bad mood,
they tend to not want
to do things that
likely should make them happy.
OK, so we can try to do that.
Now why might decision utility
and experienced utility differ?
That's of course
what we discussed
at length in the class already.
There's various
different explanations.
One is-- we're going to talk
about this a little bit,
which is inaccurate memories
of past experiences.
So you might just misremember
your past experiences,
and based on that,
you might have
poor forecasts of your future
preferences or your utility.
So this is essentially
saying people's beliefs might
be wrong in various
ways, perhaps
because people's memories are
tricking them in some ways.
People might also
have wrong beliefs
because they have some failures
to anticipate adaptation, which
is very much like
projection bias
that we talked about
already previously.
I'm going to talk about
this a little bit more.
There could be things like
emotions, which again,
is in some ways often like
projection bias, which
is about things like people
might be really angry,
or people might be hungry.
[AUDIO OUT] essentially it's
very hard for them to make
certain choices, failing
to anticipate their anger
or their hunger or other
impulses [INAUDIBLE] over time.
There's plenty funding
of other reasons,
but we talked about
this quite a lot.
And so you could
think about a lot
of what we discussed
in the course
about disconnects
between decision utility
and experienced utility.
Now I mentioned this
already a little bit.
The third part in
people's utility
is what Kahneman would call
remembered utility, which
essentially is to say,
well, when you think
about a past experience,
you might not actually
evaluate it correctly.
In a sense, you might--
as I said, I might look at
your experienced utility using
these kinds of
features, and then
I might ask you
afterwards, how did you
like certain experiences?
And then I can test, in a
way, how are you aggregating,
or how appropriately
are you aggregating
your experienced utility when
I just ask you afterwards,
how did you like
certain experiences?
And one quite interesting
feature in people's remembered
utility is what's
called-- excuse me--
duration neglect.
People tend to remember
the quality, rather than
the length of the experience.
And it seems to be also what's
called the peak-end rule, which
essentially says that
retrospective evaluations are
very much predicted
by two things,
or an average of the peak
affective response recorded
during an episode and the
end value recorded just
before the termination
of the episode.
And how do I think about this?
Well, mostly, I think this
as being very salient.
So when you think
about and I ask you
about a semester or a certain
lecture or a certain experience
that you had, maybe a
TV show or the like,
when you think about it and
try to remember how much you
enjoyed that experience, well,
what's most salient, of course,
is your latest experience.
That's what comes to mind.
The last thing you remember is
the last thing you experienced.
And if the last episode
of a TV show was terrible,
that's what comes to mind.
And you might say,
well, the whole series
was really bad, even
though maybe previously,
it was quite good.
And then the other
thing, I guess,
that seems to be
really important
is the peak, both
positive or negative.
So if something was really,
really great or really,
really bad, people
really, really
remember that, as opposed
to stuff in between.
And again, I think
that's something
that's just very salient
in people's minds,
and then in thinking about
these experiences, that's
what comes to mind.
And in studies that--
so what are these studies doing?
Well, there are these
studies that tend to measure
experienced utility
in certain ways,
either through just
measuring people's--
tracking people's
well-being over time
and then trying to predict
their remembered utility, how
did you like that experience.
That's one version.
Another version is--
let me show you.
Hang on one second--
is where people do certain
tasks specifically,
and they manipulate the
experience deliberately.
For example, there
are these tasks
which is called a cold
pressor task, which
is they ask people to put
their hands into cold water
and then vary the temperature,
or they vary the duration.
And then essentially,
you can then
try to predict people's
remembered utility
and then show things such as
duration neglect or the like.
And let me show you
what that looks like.
For example, this
is a famous study
by Schreiber and Kahneman.
They did a short
trial, which is you
put your hand into
14-degree water
for 60 seconds,
which is very cold,
or a long trial where you put
it into water for 60 second,
and then the temperature
rises to 15 degrees.
I think this--
I hope this is Celsius,
not Fahrenheit.
But anyway, it's cold.
But the point here
is that putting
your hand for 60 seconds into
14-degree water, and then
another 30 seconds
into 15-degree water,
these are both
unpleasant experiences.
So if you did each of
these things in separation,
people would say, [AUDIO OUT]
just 60 seconds of cold water.
I also don't like 30
seconds of 15-degree water.
These are both
unpleasant experiences.
So neither of them are
actually desirable.
If you ask people, if you
give people [AUDIO OUT]
do you want to experience this
again, people say, hell no.
I really don't like this, for
both of these, in separation.
But once you put them
together, the 30 seconds
of 15-degree water
is more pleasant
than the 14-degree water.
So when you do that, people
say they prefer the long trial
over the short trial.
And the reason
being is what they
remember is the last
experience, which
was not that painful, when
things got better over time.
So people's
remembered utility is
violating any sort of rules
of what you would usually
think in terms of
rationality and economics,
which is precisely because
they remember the end rather
than the overall duration.
So essentially, the
utility does not
aggregate in the way we
would think they would,
because the experience at
each point in time [AUDIO OUT]
negative.
There's more unpleasant
studies for colonoscopy.
Don't ask me about how
they got ethical approval
for those things.
But anyway, a study
[INAUDIBLE] where
getting an extra minute
where nothing bad happens.
And essentially,
the treatment group
has better experience and
memories of those kinds of--
of the overall experience.
Now that sounds kind of
like torturing people,
but in fact, if you think
about it, well, if--
in particular in medical
procedures that are unpleasant
overall, if we can help people
have better memories of those
experiences, maybe they
will be a lot likely
to come back and get future
treatments or the like.
So in a way, you might say,
what are these studies?
Why are people torturing people?
Why are researchers
torturing people?
I agree with that
notion, but in fact,
if you think about if
you wanted to design,
and if you think people are
under-using certain medical
procedures or certain medical
tests that they should be
doing--
think of dentists-- if
there's some [AUDIO OUT]
people's overall
memory or memory
of their overall
experience better by having
the end of that
experience slightly better
than the previous parts,
that could [AUDIO OUT]
helpful in generatings of
behavior that's good for people
in terms of their health,
even though, of course,
the last minute of
the actual experience
would not be pleasant.
Nobody wants to say,
would you rather
have another minute
of colonoscopy?
Absolutely not.
But maybe the overall
experience that you remember
is, in fact, better than if not.
So there's other
types of experience
that shows this
duration neglected
and peak-end evaluations.
People have shown pleasant and
unpleasant movies or contents
of movies.
They have done these
experiments with sounds or noise
of various loudness
and duration.
There's also animal [INAUDIBLE],,
where essentially animals are
given unpleasant experiences,
and then you look at what--
there's different
types of experiences
where the animal can go into one
direction or the other, press
one lever versus
another, and then
bad stuff happens in both
of them, and one of them
is worse than the other.
And then you can
look at, essentially,
do animals have similar duration
or other peak-end evaluations
of experiences?
And it seems to be very
much a phenomenon that's
also true for animals.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So then, of course,
if that's the case,
if people remember
things differently,
that will lead to violations
of the decision utility
maximizing the
experienced utility.
If you think about the
experienced utility
or the overall experienced
utility of a certain choice
that you make, in this case, I
guess, the cold pressor task,
think about this like
the integral over,
say, in this case,
I guess, 90 seconds.
In the first case,
it's 60 seconds
plus 30 seconds, 60
seconds feeling bad,
versus the 30 seconds of
putting your hand out,
which is somewhat of
a neutral experience.
If you're integrating that,
presumably, the short trial
would give you a
higher valuation
of higher, better, more
positive experience overall.
But then if you ask people,
which one do you want,
because people remember the
long trial as being less bad,
people might choose the longer
trial over the short trial
overall.
So then that leads
to, essentially,
violations of the decision
utility maximizing
the experienced utility, because
essentially, people remember
things in a biased way.
OK.
So then we talked about
this very briefly.
So so far, we talked about
different ways of measuring.
One specific thing that
people have done a lot
is just asking people simply
about their happiness and life
satisfaction.
So simply, you ask people.
There's different ways.
There are these types
of ladder questions,
how satisfied are you with your
life as a whole these days?
There's also affect
questions about like,
did you experience certain
emotions yesterday?
Did you feel angry?
Did you feel happy?
Did you feel sad?
And so on.
The ladder question is a
mixture of-- some people think
of this as life satisfaction.
Some people interpret
it as happiness.
Others would argue
that it's rather
about social comparisons.
So the ladder question
has this notion of--
I'm going to show you the
definition in a second,
or in a bit.
The ladder definition
is very much just,
on a ladder from 1 to 10,
how great could your life be?
Where are you in this ladder?
So it has very much this flavor
of some social comparison,
which is not quite ideal,
because it very well makes
it like, well, on the ladder,
how far and low are you
at the ladder?
It makes it very salient
that some people are
higher or lower than others.
So some of the
responses that you
see in those kinds of ladder
questions are about happiness,
but they potentially are
also about people comparing
each other to others in society
and so on, which might not
be necessarily the same as,
how happy are you right now
[INAUDIBLE].
Now what's problematic about
these happiness questions,
or why are economists
skeptical, or what
instances do we [AUDIO OUT]?
So just to be clear, so
some people would argue,
we should have a World
Happiness Report and GDP.
We should not maximize
GDP or look at GDP growth
as an overall
performance of society.
Instead, we should measure
subjective well-being,
and that's what we should
essentially maximize.
And policy should
be-- the objective
should be to maximize that.
So what's the pushback on that?
So part of that is
people and stuff
that we talked already about,
about remembered utility,
or people just might not
know what's good for them.
But what's wrong
with just asking
people, how happy are you?
And are people just
going to tell you,
or what's happening with that?
Yeah, so one problem,
broadly speaking,
is when you look at different
countries, different societies,
particularly, for example,
if you look at Germans,
Germans tend to be pretty
grumpy and not super happy.
So when you ask a
German, how are you
doing, the typical German would
say, OK, by which they mean,
actually pretty good.
If you ask a typical
American, how are you doing,
they say, amazing.
They probably mean, pretty good.
So when people give
you certain statements,
there's lots of cultural
and other aspect
that make comparison,
particularly across societies,
kind of tricky.
You might think people
in Latin America tend
to report higher
levels of happiness
because that's a cultural thing,
which might be that they're
actually happier, or it
might be that that's just
the thing that you're
supposed to exhibit.
While people in some other
states, Scandinavia, Germany,
et cetera, might be,
in fact, quite happy,
but what they report to you
is just some moderate level
of enthusiasm overall.
So one is cultural
comparison is quite hard
using those types of questions.
There's lots of Gallup
surveys that people
have done at large scales.
It's the Gallup world
happiness, or whatever, surveys.
There's huge amounts of data
that are being collected.
They're a nationally
representative surveys,
and so on and so forth.
So those data are available.
Of course, there's questions
of, in some places,
it's much harder
to collect these
than in others, and
so on and so forth.
And some people don't
reply to surveys,
and so on and so forth.
For example, the elderly
might be much less
likely to answer some
surveys, or some people
without phones or internet,
and so on and so forth,
you might not be
able to reach them.
But in principle, you can
solve all of those issues.
But I think that it's
just cost of use.
The reference dependence is
a very interesting issue,
because in some ways, you might
say, well, now your income,
but then your reference
point goes off.
Something happens to
your reported happiness?
But presumably you're
happier than before?
So that [AUDIO OUT].
On the other hand,
utility might, in fact,
be very much
reference-dependent.
For example, you might
compare yourself to others.
And then inequality,
for example,
might be extremely important
for people's happiness.
And one of the things
that people argue is that,
for example, [INAUDIBLE]
the GDP, also for the US--
GDP in many places has
gone up quite a bit,
but happiness has not increased.
And people argue that's because,
in part, inequality also
went up a lot.
And if then inequality really
makes people deeply unhappy,
well, that is
important, and we should
incorporate that in some ways
in our considerations overall.
But you see, that causes tricky
issues, because in one case,
doubling everybody's income,
and presumably, people
should be happier, because
their living standard goes up.
So presumably, there, even
if happiness doesn't go up,
presumably, because living
standards have gone up,
and something is going wrong
if I don't see increased
happiness in terms
of measurement--
on the other hand, there might
be very much real issues about,
inequality is quite important,
and reference-dependent matters
for people's happiness
and well-being,
in the sense that what
really might matter a lot
is relative income rather
than absolute income,
and we should capture that
in some meaningful way.
Oops.
Sorry.
In particular,
there's lots of issues
with, depending on
what I focus you
on when I ask
certain questions, I
can get very, very
different answers.
And one, for example,
example of this
is a paper by
Strack et. al. that
looked at the correlation
between general happiness
and happiness with dating.
And so what they did
is a very simple thing.
They essentially
just manipulated
the order of questions.
So first, they asked
people about how happy
are you in general.
And then they asked
people, how happy
are you with your dating life?
And in a different
subsample, they
asked people, how happy are
you with the dating life,
and then asked people about
their general happiness.
And what that does,
essentially, it
focuses people very much about
dating as part of their life
being important and
for their happiness.
And similarly, I think
this is exactly what Maya
was saying as well.
We need to ask, as you know,
about the ladder question,
which is about other
questions about, depending
on how I phrase the question, I
can get very different answers
and what you're saying.
So that makes it very
tricky to figure out
which questions should
we use, how much
weight should be put on it.
And even things like the
order of questions matter.
Matters quite a bit, which
makes economists very nervous
and so on, and then that's
why, in part, economists
would argue that we really
should have revealed preference
and choice.
Now on the other hand, I very
much think the questions,
when you just ask people
and say, I'm deeply unhappy,
that has some content, and
there's information there.
And so then the
question is, well,
how do we weigh
these considerations?
On the one hand, the
survey instrument
is really just very fragile,
and we don't measure very much.
On the other hand, there's
useful information here
that we should be
incorporating somehow.
So I just wanted to have you--
that caveat in mind.
And so let's now
look at some data
that people have collected.
So what's a very
nice source overall
is what's called Our
World in Data, which
has lots of interesting
graphs and figures
where you can look at
happiness and all sorts
of things data on the world.
And when you look at life
satisfaction around the globe,
this is very much the ladder
question here, which you see,
exactly as I was saying.
There's the ladder
from zero to 10.
And again, the ladder question
is very much something
hierarchical and makes
inequality or relative
comparisons quite salient.
Even if it only asks you
about your worst or your best
possible life for yourself,
it does have the feeling
that really, it's about
comparing yourself to others.
But anyway, that's very
much used in many cases.
Often people will call
it life satisfaction,
but even here, they also
call it happiness overall.
This is from the World
Happiness Report.
And what you see is
that, in general,
rich countries tend to be--
report higher happiness,
Scandinavian countries
in particular.
The US is reasonably happy.
Europe is quite happy.
And then if you go
to poorer countries,
in particular in
Africa, they tend
to report a lot lower
happiness level.
When you look at comparisons
across countries,
you see a very
clear relationship.
Rich countries
tend to be a lot--
report much higher
life satisfaction
compared to poor countries.
That's a very clear association.
That's true, both
across countries
but also true within countries.
So what this graph
here shows you
is the average
income in a country.
And then these arrows
show you the gradient.
Within the slope
of the arrows is
the gradient within countries.
And what you see
is essentially--
so this is comparing
people within countries,
rich versus poor countries.
If you increase income within a
country by $1,000 or something,
how much does people's
happiness go up?
And what you see is all
of those countries have--
almost all countries have
increasing gradients,
which tells you that, both
within and across countries,
richer people report
higher life satisfactions
compared to poorer people.
Similarly, that's also
true for mental health.
So these are all questions
about subjective well-being,
how happy are you overall,
asking the overall population.
But if you try to look at
mental health conditions
in terms of particularly
depression and anxiety, so
using clear definitions
and psychiatric disorders
for depression and anxiety
and also for other conditions,
you find that the poor
in any given location
are more likely to suffer from
depression and/or anxiety.
Interestingly, the
prevalence of depression,
in fact, also and anxiety,
is higher in rich countries.
There's a lot of questions
about measurement problems,
like is it really
measuring the same thing,
and so on and so forth.
But it could also be there's
other factors involved,
in particular, issues
such as inequality.
And it could just be
that really, what's
really important is
relative income as opposed
to absolute income.
Now we know also that
anti-poverty programs improve
mental health in
various ways, including
things like cash transfers and
other anti-poverty programs.
So this is an
overview of studies.
This is essentially a
recent meta-analysis
that we did for some
[INAUDIBLE] paper of mine.
And what you see
here is a number
of different interventions,
both cash transfers
and other anti-poverty
programs, which
are more broader programs.
And what you see here is the
treatment effect estimated
in the different studies.
These are overall poverty
anti-poverty programs.
These are cash
transfer programs.
But overall, essentially,
the overwhelming answer
is that once you give people
cash or reduce their poverty,
that improves their
mental health, as measured
by different-- these are PWB,
means psychological well-being
indices.
This is also depression
screening scores and so on.
So by various measures of
people's mental health,
giving people more money
improves their mental health.
So that's true at the extreme in
terms of really mental illness,
depressive and
anxiety disorders.
It's also true
for other measures
of psychological well-being.
If you just give people cash,
they report higher happiness,
in addition to what
I told you before,
this being true in
the cross section.
Now interestingly,
we also tend to think
that others are less happy
than they say they are.
So if we just ask
people, how happy
are other people
in your country,
almost every country
in the world,
what you find is
that people tend
to say the fraction that people
actually say that they're
very happy or rather
happy is lower
than they actually say they are,
which is an interesting fact.
Now this-- as we talked about
this already a little bit--
how is life satisfaction
and happiness related
to life events?
In terms of when you look
at different life events--
it's quite interesting
that a lot of life events
tend to affect people's
reported well-being or life
satisfaction a lot.
For many events, including
stuff like widowhood or divorce
or marriage and other types of
events, or winning the lottery,
these effects are very much
transitory, which is to say,
when something really
bad to somebody happens,
their happiness goes down a lot.
But it tends to
recover quite a bit.
This is what we
talked about before.
People are quite
adaptive to many changes,
and they adjust quite well.
This is what people call the
psychological immune system,
except for a few things,
including unemployment.
And one potential reason is
that, for example, unemployment
might also cause
things like depression.
And once you're
really depressed,
that doesn't really go back
over [INAUDIBLE] that easily.
That's true for women.
It's also true for men overall.
There's also some
other issues which
you want to be careful of
whether to interpret some
of this data, which is there's
called this evolution of latent
situations, which is when you
look at things like divorce,
it tends to be that people--
when you look at
people's divorce,
you might say,
well, divorce makes
them happier in some ways.
But really, what seems to be--
or you would look
at this and say,
marriage makes
people less happy.
But really, what
seems to be the case
is that people build
up to a positive event,
and then that peaks positive or
negatively and then essentially
goes back to what's before.
For example, unemployment,
things tend to go worse,
even before people become
unemployed, which seems to say,
people tend to-- these
underlying events,
people tend to
anticipate them already
psychologically in some ways.
Now, this is what I
was saying before.
When you look at
comparisons over time,
you get sometimes these
situations where, particularly
in places including
in China, but also
in the US, where real income
has risen a lot in many places,
but yet people's
life satisfaction
does not tend to increase.
Why is that?
Well, that's, in part, I think,
because of inequality going up,
but [INAUDIBLE]
inequality really
staying the same and relative
income really being important.
Could be other things going on.
For example, pollution is
really bad for people's health,
mental health, but also
their happiness and so on.
It could also just be that
people's reference points
adjust, which is just, you
make everybody twice as happy,
and now everybody's-- the
reference point goes up,
even though their overall
objective well-being standards,
in terms of how much can
they consume, et cetera,
has gone up a lot.
Now this is quite interesting
data now on ceiling effects.
So there's some
controversy over this.
Some people are
arguing that when
you give people more
money, at some point,
there's a ceiling effect.
It doesn't really make
them happier anymore.
Now when you look at
this graph here-- let
me go back for a second.
When you look at these
graphs here, this--
whoops, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
One second.
When you look at
this graph here,
it just doesn't look at
all like ceiling effect.
This looks like, essentially,
self-reported life satisfaction
as measured by these
ladder question,
essentially, is increasing, and
there seems to be no ceiling,
or it doesn't seem to be
flattening in any way.
When you look at
this one as well,
it seems to be if you increase
income by $1,000, at any level,
it seems to be that reported
life satisfaction goes up.
So again, that doesn't
look like a ceiling effect.
And that's true as well if you
look at these questions here.
Gallup had done these
surveys in the US.
When you look at the
ladder question, which
is this one here, when you look
at annual income in the US,
once you increase
people's income,
their mean ladder
score, which is here
on the axis on the
right, tends to go up
pretty much monotonically.
Maybe it's a little
bit flattening,
but essentially, it goes up.
So people report higher
life satisfaction
when they have higher income.
But when you look at
people's affect, both things
like positive affect, which
is like happiness, smiling,
enjoyment, not being blue,
being stress-free and so on,
what you see is-- in
particular, this is for the US.
When you go from something
like $10,000 to $20,000
to $40,000 per year
of income, there's
a clear increase over time.
So being poor is really--
or poor in the US,
it is really, really
bad for your affect
and for your reported
well-being overall.
But once you reach something
like $50,000, $60,000, $70,000
in the US, it seems
to me that there's
no effect on positive affect,
feeling blue, stress-free
and so on.
So one interpretation of that
is that if we take these affect
questions as more like a
measure of experienced utility
and happiness in any
given life, essentially,
having something like $70,000,
$80,000 per year in the US--
granted, this is from
2009, so maybe this number
has gone a little bit higher.
But that number is sufficient to
make people sufficiently happy,
and beyond that,
doubling of income
will not do very much on
how much you smile every day
and how happy you are as
a measure of those things.
In contrast, if I ask you the
ladder question, which again,
is very much about comparison,
about how you feel yourself
compared to somebody
else in society,
going from $100,000 to $200,000
will make, potentially, still
quite a big difference.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So then let me--
this is among the most
interesting parts of these
kinds of studies, is the
question about what, in fact--
so if not just income--
so if you know income
essentially-- overall,
if you're rich, you're
going to be happier
compared to if you're poor.
But again, it
seems to be really,
if you want to not
be unhappy, having
income above $50,000 in
the US is really important.
Beyond that, it doesn't seem
to do very much anymore.
But now what other things
matter quite a bit?
And this is a very
simple exercise.
So what they did is,
this is [INAUDIBLE]..
They looked at the
Gallup survey questions
from 450,000 Americans.
And what they did is,
for each of these four
measures of
psychological well-being,
which is these here, positive
affect, not blue, stress-free,
and the ladder questions,
they were first
just trying to predict,
what is the regression
coefficient of high income?
So if you just split
the sample in two
and look at high income
versus low income,
what is the regression
coefficients of that?
They're trying to interpret
that as causal effect, which,
of course, is a
little problematic.
But you can think of
this as the question,
if I wanted to try to predict
how happy you are, what do I
need to know about you?
What are the factors that I need
to know about you if I wanted
to predict how happy you are in
your life on any point in time?
If you wanted to know,
20 years from now,
are you going to
be happy or not,
what are the things that you
need to know about yourself?
And so it turns out that
high income is predictive.
So there's some
coefficient that says
that if you have higher
income, you're somewhat
more likely to have
positive affect,
less likely to feel blue or
less likely to be stressed,
and a lot more likely to give
a higher answer in the ladder
questions.
So in some sense,
higher income is good.
And then what the
table does is it
looks at-- it normalizes
high income to 1
and then shows you other
characteristics and says,
OK, if I knew another about you,
are you religious versus not
and so on, what is the relative
coefficient of that compared
to a high versus low income?
OK?
So for example, if
you're old, you're--
so a positive
coefficient means you're
happier or more likely to
have positive affect here,
and a negative, the opposite,
I guess, for positive affect
here.
So if you're old, for
example, older people,
at least in the US, tend to
report higher positive affect.
So that's good news for you.
In 20, 30 years, you'll
be likely to be happier.
It turns out that religious
people, for example,
tend to be more--
report more positive
affect compared
to non-religious people.
And the magnitude of these
effects is pretty large.
That is to say--
1.16 is to say, if you
compare religious--
if I knew about you, are
you religious versus not,
that is as predictive
as knowing about you,
are you rich versus not, are
you in the upper or lower half
of this income distribution?
So that's quite
important in terms
of trying to predict
whether people are happy.
Now what's particularly striking
here when you look at this
here is alone, smoker, and
headache, and particularly
pain.
I want to emphasize
the alone here.
Social relationships or
people being in relationships
with friends or in
family or with partners
is extremely predictive
of people's well-being.
This is what I was
talking about before when
it came to social preferences.
Investing in social
relationships in one way is--
A, of course.
Making other people happy
and being nice is good.
But in a way, you
think about investing
or being nice to
others and investing
in a social relationship.
It's very much an investment
in your future well-being.
And the magnitudes
here are enormous.
Now another way
you could do is--
so here, you could
say, well, what
should I do to make me
happier in the future?
So one thing you could
do is just look at data.
do is look at data.
And well, what are these
predictors [AUDIO OUT]
people happy?
These are all correlations.
You want to be careful.
[AUDIO OUT] tells you
something about, if you
want to be happy in 20 years,
things you want to invest in,
these numbers are probably
a pretty good start.
[AUDIO OUT] your health seems
to be quite a good idea.
Smoking, for
example, not so much.
Now another thing you
could do is just ask people
at the above and
just [AUDIO OUT]
about what they should have or
could have done in their life.
What do you think people said?
So this is an
Australian nurse who
recorded the experience
from palliative care
as end of life experiences
and asked people about--
or she did not simply ask,
but she was just recording
what people are saying.
What are the top five regrets?
What would you think they are?
AUDIENCE: Not spending
enough time with family?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Mm-hmm.
Wished I had worked
less, somebody else says.
Good enough.
So essentially, what people tend
to say is a combination of they
wished they had
been more social,
they wished they had
expressed their feelings more,
they had had been more true to
themselves in some ways and not
done things that
others wanted them
to do but rather spend more time
with their friends and family
and so on.
Now you want to be a little
bit careful with this.
Again, there's issues
with remembered utility.
It's also issues with if you are
alone at the end of your life,
you might be quite
unhappy because of that.
Be careful how to
interpret that.
But I think we can actually
learn quite a bit about this.
In some ways, if you think
about certain choices
you make in life, understanding
some of these issues
seem to be quite
important overall.
And when you think about
what should you maximize,
it seems to be that maximizing
income, if that comes
at the cost of not
having friends,
seems to be not a
good idea if you want
to be happy in the long run.
Another thing that
people-- by the way
here, this is not in
here-- tend to emphasize
quite a lot is having
a meaningful job
or having work that they
believe in in terms of something
meaningful as opposed
to maximizing income,
which seems quite important.
OK.
So then what kinds
of things then could
you do to make yourself happier?
And I have a few things
written down here.
So one of the thing
things that I really is
invest in and maintain
social relationships.
Small acts can make
big differences,
as we talked about, of
letters of gratitude
or random acts of kindness.
These are very small
things that you could do.
Of course, you can do also
really important things.
It matters quite a lot how
much you help your friends
or how much you
invest in others.
Again, that's partially
reflective of just being
pro-social and being
nice to others,
but you can think of
this very much as--
neurotically in some ways,
you can think of this
also as investing in your
own happiness in the future.
Choosing meaningful work over
money seems really important.
If you think about what
to do with your life,
there's so much talent
at MIT, and I sometimes
wish that talent would go more
into more meaningful things,
or because it's society
or making society better
overall, as opposed to
some perhaps potentially
[INAUDIBLE] that pay
you a lot of money.
That's, in some sense,
potentially socially optimal
in terms of just
use MIT's talents
or MIT students' talents for
useful things in the world.
But if you're just
selfish and want
to make yourself happy
in 20 years from now,
it seems to me that just
maximizing income is just not
what's going to get you there.
So it seems to be like
being rich is certainly
glamorous and
exciting, but in fact,
if that comes at the cost
of your health, [INAUDIBLE],,
and your friendships,
most likely,
or at the cost of
having a meaningful job
that you actually believe
in and think is useful,
that's not going to make
you happy in the long run.
So for those of you thinking
about what kind of work
to pursue in the future,
keep that in mind.
And then I have two
more things here
in my list, which
is seeking support
to improve your mental health
and reduce social media usage.
So what do I mean by that?
So psychotherapies
have very much
been shown to be effective in
reducing depression, anxiety,
and so on.
Yet people tend to not
make use of those services.
Now why is that?
There's obvious reasons, which
is stigma, shame, and on.
There's also potentially
misperceptions, projection
bias.
Also depression
itself, for example,
could precisely generate
these kinds of beliefs.
There could also be
other behavioral biases
like other health conditions,
where people just don't
like to see doctors and so on.
Now another way to
view this is to say,
well, you might think
that psychotherapy
is really important for
depression and anxiety,
but psychotherapy could
also be viewed as a coach
to make you happy.
Just think about this
as a happiness coach.
It might help you figure
out your objective function
in life, what really makes you
happy, and how to pursue that.
And that's regardless
of depression, anxiety,
or any mental disorders.
It's to say, think about sports.
In sports, you get a coach
to be a better tennis
player or whatever, soccer
or whatever sports you do.
That's a very
natural thing to do.
People help you to do better.
Now why not have a coach for
many other things in life,
including how to
be happier and how
to lead a life that
makes you satisfied?
In some sense, if
you're maximizing
your wrong objective
function, which again, could
be you just maximize
money over other things,
if a therapist helped
you do that or helped you
correct that, that could be
extremely valuable and helpful.
And again, that's in the absence
of any serious mental illness.
That's just for
the average person.
Having somebody to talk to to
help you optimize your life
and mental well-being
seems to be extremely
important and worth trying.
Second, about social media.
So there's a recent paper
that's quite intriguing.
Or there's actually
a couple papers,
but let me just
mention one, which
is by Alcott et al that
randomizes paying students
to stay off Facebook
for a month.
This was before the 2018
election, midterm election,
which is, in some sense,
perhaps relevant in some ways.
The timing might matter
for some of these results.
So what they find is that
getting people to pay-- you
have to pay students
quite a lot to do this.
So students, you have
to pay them like $50,
and otherwise, they're
not willing to do this.
When you do that, people
reduce their online activities.
They also reduce their
factual new knowledge,
political polarization and
so on, all kinds of things
that you might expect.
Then you see increased
subjective well-being,
both happiness but also
reduced depression.
So students are happier,
quite a bit happier
by doing that
Moreover, there seem
to be large,
persistent reductions
in post-experiment
Facebook usage.
That is to say, once
the experiment is over,
lots of students who have
been paid to stay off Facebook
tend to do that, or
to continue doing
that, which very much seems
to say that it's a habit good.
Perhaps there's
also some learning
involved as students learn that
they're now happier overall.
Now that always leads
to the question, well,
why are people then on Facebook
if it doesn't make them happy?
And does it have to
do with peer pressure?
Does it have to do
with habit formation?
Does it have to do with
self-control problems?
biased beliefs and so on?
But overall in some
ways, I think the reason
that I show this evidence is,
when you think about your life
or things that you
do in your life,
you want to think about
what are the things that you
do in your life?
What are the things that
make you happy or not?
And perhaps experimenting
with those kinds of things,
or just looking at
data from studies
seems like a very
reasonable thing to do.
So it could well be
that social media
makes you really happy in
connecting with your friends.
In particular right now, you
think that's really helpful,
because you can
stay in touch if you
need to talk online
and so on and so forth,
and that's truly a thing
that's worth doing.
So that could really be very
beneficial for your happiness
overall, but it might
also be that there's
large costs of not, coming
from perhaps social comparison
or just seeing everybody
happy on Facebook,
or whatever people
post selectively
makes it look like people are
way happier than they actually
are.
And then that makes people
feel bad about themselves,
seeing others post overall.
But I think the
reason why I show
you this is I want you
to think about or be more
conscious about, what are
the things that do make you,
in fact, happier and try to
invest in those that seem
to make you happier overall.
So some of these things
you could obviously
experiment with.
For example, you can
obviously turn off
your Facebook or
Instagram, whatever,
very quickly and easily.
Other things, of
course-- the stuff
that I showed you in
the very long run,
like the Kahneman here, these
kinds of data, of course,
it's much harder to
experiment with that.
It's harder to say, I'm going
to be religious for a month,
from now on, and then
see, are you happier?
But it is worth to
think about, what
are the things that
you're really pursuing,
and are these things going
to be making you happy?
Not just right now
and, is this just
doing some things
because your friends want
it or some other
influence that you have,
as opposed to what are the
things that you really want,
and what are the things that
are going to make you happy,
not just this month or
next month, but five 10,
20 years from now?
Because a lot of
choices that you
make in the next
couple of years will
be very persistent in terms
of depending on what jobs
you choose, what kinds
of friendships you have,
what kind of partners
you have, and so on,
will be very much
persistent for a long time
in terms of determining
your long run happiness.
And so that's a very useful
thing to think about.
Let me see.
So what do people think?
I guess, at some
point, hopefully--
so Cubek is monitoring the
llama situation, I hope.
We'll see about that,
because hopefully,
that makes people happier.
But what do people think is--
why are people on Facebook if
it doesn't make them happy?
So it could be
essentially issues
with present bias or the
like, that any point in time,
there's some temptations of
perhaps posting or the like,
and then that makes you
happy in the very short run.
But in the long run
overall, then that's
not really helping you overall,
and there's essentially
some self-control
problems in some ways.
In particular right
now-- and so to be clear,
the study that was done
here-- and I actually talked
to [INAUDIBLE] some of the
authors of the study would also
tell me, if you did
the study right now,
we would find the opposite,
because now, in fact,
Facebook or any
other social media
helps people stay in touch, and
there's some positive benefits.
So what you're saying is,
well, presumably, Facebook
was developed early on.
Or the reason why
it's successful
is because it really
helped people connect
to each other in some ways.
And people thought there
were some benefits from that.
And that's particularly
true if you're not
in the same place physically.
And particularly
right now, then there
are these benefits overall.
And then there's a
question of, well,
what are the costs
and benefits of that?
And maybe people misperceive
some of these or the like.
What I'm trying to
encourage you is to say,
well, there's ways
to learn about this.
And Facebook is actually
a very good example
where you could learn very
easily, where you just say,
let's turn it off for a
month and see what happens.
You could also-- there's some
other activities where you say,
let's do more sports, or let's
get up earlier in the morning
or sleep more at night.
There's some things that are
quite easy to experiment with.
Other stuff, as I said,
becoming religious versus not,
is much trickier to experiment
with, or being healthy
versus not.
In some sense, it's just a
very much long run effect.
But exactly as you said, people
have never actually experienced
any of this, so
how would you know
how you're going to be happier?
There's also some public
goods issues and some issues
of externalities [INAUDIBLE].
If all of [AUDIO OUT] are on
social media and you are not,
you're a bit of an outsider,
and that will make you likely
very--
or likely not increase
your happiness.
But it might well be that if
everybody decides to go off
social media, then
in some sense,
you don't have to
rely on social media
to go to parties or
whatever and so on.
And so there might be
also some coordination
issues, potentially.
So conditional on everybody
being on Facebook around you,
you might want to be on Facebook
or whatever other social media.
But if that's not
the case, then--
so it could be for
every single person.
Every single person could be
happier if everybody else were
not on social media, but
conditional on that everybody
is on social media,
that's not the case.
And what I'm saying here is, we
tend to do the same things over
and over again.
As Maya was saying,
is what if we just
experiment more off of this and
we did costs, perhaps long run,
benefits.
There's default effects,
of course, and so on that
keep us from experimenting.
But if you think about it,
if you could make yourself
just a little bit happier
every day for many, many years,
it seems to be worth
experimenting a lot.
I would very much encourage
you to go and try out
new things in life that
potentially make you happier.
[INAUDIBLE] has as a nice--
I hope this is still
working, the link,
but it has a very
nice New York Times
article that argues that
[INAUDIBLE] experiment more
and try to figure out
what makes us happier.
Any other thoughts on
social media or Facebook?
OK.
So that's all I have for now.
Next time, we're going
to talk about policy.
That's the last lecture.
Please do read
Thaler and Sunstein.
Peluk tells me the
llama is not here yet,
neither in my private room where
the llama might be otherwise.
I'll sit here just to wait.
I think the announced
time is 2:30,
so that's in four minutes.
So if you have to run,
of course, that's fine.
Otherwise, I'm just going
to stick around and wait.
If you want to talk
about more, I'd
love to know more about why
people are experimenting more.
I also would love to know
more about how people think.
So one thing I was
mentioning here
is that, while social
media might be bad
and there might be
detrimental effects,
in particular coming from social
comparisons, which is to say,
look.
You see everybody
on Instagram looks
like they have a glamorous life
and are happy all the time.
You see that, and that might
make you feel depressed.
By the way, that
might also lead you
to [AUDIO OUT] glamorous
pictures yourself.
So you might reinforce
the whole issue overall.
I think there surely are
some downs, actually.
But there's also
potential upsides
of connecting people
online, in particular
that I'm trying to work on.
[AUDIO OUT] if anybody has some
small things [INAUDIBLE] could
do right now online to help
people be more connected,
and less lonely,
and less depressed.